The solution to this compound inequality is negative infinity to negative 1
union 4 to infinity. How did you do? Did you get it right? If so, great work.
Let's see how we got that. Once again, I'm going to solve these inequalities
independently and I'm going to start skipping a step or two. When I'm solving
this inequality, I want to subtract 3x from both sides, which gives me 3x plus 5
is less than 2. Subtracting 5 from both sides, gives me 3x is less than negative
3. Divide both sides by 3, and I get x is less than negative 1. When I solve
this inequality, I'm going to skip the steps where I'm showing what I'm adding
or subtracting to each side of the equation. In other words, here, I want to
subtract x from both sides. When I subtract x from 2x, I am simply left with x
plus 7 on the left side and when I subtract x from the right side, x minus x is
0, so I get x plus 7 is 11. And when I subtract 7 from both sides, I get x is
greater than 11 minus 7, which is 4. I have x is less than negative 1 or x is
greater than 4. Let's see what that looks like on a number line. When I graph
the solution of x is less than negative 1 on the number line, I have a
parenthesis because it's less than, and I know it's going to the left because
it's less than. Similarly, x is greater than 4 We've put a parenthesis at 4 and
since it's greater than, we're going to the right. The solution on the number
line makes it really easy to write in interval notation. Since this arrow is
going off to negative infinity, we start at negative infinity and we have to
stop at negative 1. Since it's an or we have a union, and then we start up again
at 4 and the arrow is going to positive infinity.
Let's go ahead and try one more compound inequality.